ايضا نتابع هذه الاخبار العاجله عن مسؤول
الاسرائيلي الجيش يقيم الوضع بعد القصف
الصاروخي ونشاهد الان صور اجتماع رئيس
هيئه الاركان مع رئيس جهاز المخابرات لبحث
التطورات الشماليه اسرائيل
معنا من راس ان نقول على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه مراسل الجزيره
الياس هل من جديد في الوضع وماذا عن هذا
الاجتماع في انتظار الاجتماع الجهاز
الامني من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بالفعل ونحن امام تصعيد غير مسبوق على
الاقل منذ الحرب والعدوان الاسرائيلي على
لبنان في عام 2006 هذا بحيث من حيث عدد
الصواريخ التي اطلقت في الرشقات المتتاليه
هنا على القطاع الغربي للحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه التقديرات لدى اجهزه الامن
الاسرائيليه وتحديدا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يشير الى ان نحو اربعه وثلاثين 34 صاروخا
اطلق من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه المتاخمه للحدود القبه
الحديديه بحسب التقديرات الاوليه تمكنت من
اعتراض 25 صاروخا على الاقل فيما سقط خمسه
صواريخ اخرين او اخرى في مناطقة مفتوحه في
المناطق المتاخمه للحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه المصادر الاوليه تشير الى وقوع
اصابتين في بلده فاصوطه العربيه وفي بلده
يانور حيث اصيب شخصان هناك بجروحا طفيفه
ونقل على اثرها الى مستشفى نهاريه القريبه
هنا الحدود اللبنانيه
وعلى ما يبدو بعض الصواريخ الاخرى سقطت
على مقلوبه من السياج الامني او داخل
الاراضي اللبنانيه المهم الان هو ان
اسرائيل لم ترد عسكريا حتى هذه الساعه هذا
ما يؤكده على الاقل الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
ردا لم ياتي حتى الان وعاده ما كنا نرى
ردا سريعا من جانب المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
على كل خلق لوقف اطلاق النار الذي تحقق في
عام 2006 ضمن القرار 170 واحد التابع
التابع من الامم المتحده لكن هذه المره
اسرائيل يبدو انها تتريث في الرد على
الاقل الجيش الاسرائيلي والمصادر العسكريه
الاسرائيليه لا تتحدث عن رد مباشر على هذه
العمليه لكن واضح من ان اجتماع المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
ودعوه رئيس الوزراء الى انعقاده هذا
المجلس بعد
شهرين دون انعقاد هذا يدلل على ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تريد ان تدرس بعنايه الرد على
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ هذا الاطلاق غير
المسبوق كما اشرت منذ عام 2006
وكذلك جراد
نعم هذا هذا ما تؤكده المصادر العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وهذا
يدلل على ان جهات من الجانب الاسرائيلي
تشير الى ان فصائل فلسطينيه هي التي تقف
وراء تنفيذ هذا الاطلاق لكن رغم ذلك
الجانب الاسرائيلي يقول حتى ولو كان كانت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه البلدات في اسرائيل هذا
المساء فانها لن تستطيع ان تفعل ذلك بدون
تنسيق وبدون موافقه وبدون ضوء اخضر من حزب
الله والان اسرائيل تريد ان تدرس كيف
سيكون ردها هل سيكون هذا الرد ردا محدودا
على مصادر اطلاق النار على استهداف مواقع
فلسطينيه ام ان الرد الذي ستقوم به ربما
يجر الى مواجهه واسعه ليس بالضروره ان
تكون حربا كبيره كالتي شهدناها في العام
2006 لكن ان تكون
مواجهه لايام معدوده ينضم فيها حزب الله
الى هذه المعادله